allies of a jailed russian opposition
figure are calling for new protests next
weekend following sometimes
violent encounters with authorities
saturday in more than 100
cities in russia russian officials
detained more than 3 700 demonstrators
seeking freedom for a lexi navalny state
department correspondent rich edson has
the latest tonight on how the biden
administration is reacting
[Applause]
moscow protesters this weekend confront
police in riot gear
demanding the russian government release
alexei navalny
an activist and antagonist of president
vladimir putin
and only days into a new administration
the u.s
is condemning the russian government we
are very concerned about their behavior
whether it's novelty whether it's the
solar winds or whether it's reports of
bounties on the heads of
of americans in afghanistan the white
house says it's requested an
intelligence review of that behavior
and is also calling on the russian
government to release navalny
and the thousands arrested for
peacefully protesting for his release
though the biden administration also
quickly agreed to extend the final
nuclear arms treaty between the two
countries
citing its limits on weapons remember
ronald reagan used to say
trust but verify i say don't trust
only verify and the new start treaty
allows us to do this i think it should
i think it's a right decision by the new
biden team to extend it the top
republican on the senate foreign
relations committee criticized the
five-year extension of new start
as too long and as a result quote we
should expect the russians to continue
to expand and improve their tactical
nuclear weapons
and exotic delivery systems the russian
government is forecasting a continued
poor relationship with the united states
the deputy foreign minister sergey
ryabkov tells a russian outlet
that officials there don't expect
anything good from the new
administration
accusing american counterparts of
building their careers
slinging mud at russia brett
rich thank you let's talk about russia
and impeachment other topics
tonight with arkansas senator tom cotton
senator thanks for being here
thanks for having me on brett i want to
start with that last piece about russia
you put out a statement
on thursday saying president biden is
giving a gift of vladimir putin by
unconditionally extending the new start
treaty
after four years of unfounded hysterical
attacks on president trump
and chess thumping about russia it
appears that president biden and the
democrats have immediately reverted to
their old weak
dovish ways he is calling on
russia to release navalny among other
things
you're saying this is not good enough as
far as russia policy
well brett words are nice and russia
should uh
release mr navalny but the number one
priority for vladimir putin was a
unconditional extension
of the new start treaty because that
treaty favors russia
it does not cover the vast arsenal of
tactical nuclear weapons that russia has
or some of its novel delivery systems
like undersea
delivery systems or nuclear powered
cruise missiles and hypersonic glide
vehicles that's why vladimir putin
wanted it extended without condition
it's also a bilateral treaty at a time
when china's growing nuclear arms
threatened to overmatch the united
states when combined with russia
and their nuclear arms i don't
understand why joe biden would have
given
vladimir putin exactly what he wanted on
his first full day in office without
demanding significant concessions in
return
so you're saying he's soft on russia
well again the democrats have a long
history going back to the cold war and
the soviet incarnation
of russia of being very dovish when it
comes to dealing with moscow now for
four years they beat their chess like
jack ryan and other cold warriors
as if they were the only ones who would
stand up to vladimir putin
when in fact the trump administration
had a much tougher line on russia
than previous administrations of both
parties now joe biden comes into office
and the very first thing he does
is grant a unconditional extension of a
one-sided arms treaty it's very
disappointing
and it will endanger our national
security in the long run
senator let's talk about impeachment the
article of impeachment will be walked
over
to your side of the capitol uh tonight
and then it starts february 8th your
thoughts about where things stand and
what
should be happening well brett you're
right that the house managers will
present the
article impeachment tonight senators
will be sworn in tomorrow then we'll
take a brief pause for a couple weeks so
the president's legal team can prepare
his defense something they were denied
in the house
a chance for a fair hearing and due
process i don't think this trial though
is within the senate's constitutional
authority
the impeachment power is designed to
convict and remove office holders from
office the constitution explicitly says
it applies to the president the vice
president and civil
officers now donald trump is none of
those he is a private citizen and i
think most
americans are going to think by the
middle of february it's very strange
that the senate is spending its time
trying to convict and remove from office
a man who left
office almost a month ago there are many
other pressing priorities on which we
could be focused
how many republicans do you think at the
end of this will vote
to convict brett i can't speak for my
fellow republicans uh but i can say
that more and more have told me as
they've studied the matter
they've come around to my view of things
as i announced the day the house
impeached the president is that this is
beyond the constitutional authority of
the senate to conduct a trial to convict
and remove from office a man who left
office last week
you know the man who left office did
tweet about you
and suggested a number of people would
get primaried
coming up if they didn't stand with the
president
in this impeachment mess he
tweeted out on january 4th before the
incidents
on january 6 mentioning you in
particular
what do you think about the political
power of now former president trump
well brett i declined to try to overturn
the results of the presidential election
when congress met to
count electoral votes on january 6. for
the same reason i don't think congress
should proceed
with this impeachment trial i am
standing up to the constitution
fidelity to the constitution has to be
our lodestar at all times
and just like it's beyond congress's
power to reverse the results of the
electoral
college it's beyond our power to proceed
with an impeachment proceeding
after the impeached official has left
office i don't think so much about the
politics of this question
as faithfulness to the constitution
yeah but i'm asking you a political
question as far as the power
of the political power of donald trump
and
possibly even uh trump supporters and
how much that factors into your party
going forward
well the president is still very popular
with republicans across the country
and he has said he wants to stay engaged
in politics as the former president
i would say though that if you try to do
the right thing and especially if you
try to uphold the constitution
the ships will usually fall in the right
way when it comes to the politics
but january 6th you've spoken out about
that
and what happened did you believe the
president president trump
incited that mob brett
the president called forth a crowd on
january 6
and for many weeks he had been saying
that there was some chance to reverse
the results of the election
and extend to him a second term that
simply wasn't going to happen now
the main people who are responsible for
the mob that attacked the capital
were the violent members of that mob who
are facing significant jail time now and
arrests are ongoing
those are the main people who are
responsible for the violence that we had
at the capitol
senator i just have a few seconds left
but i do want to try to give you an
opportunity to
straighten something out were you
straightforward
with voters about your military service
you're a decorated veteran
but there's a story a couple of stories
popping up about you saying that you
were an army ranger
yeah thanks brett i graduated from the
ranger school i wore the ranger tab in
combat 101st airborne in iraq
this is not about my military record
this is about my politics
ranger regiment legends like general
scottie miller or general
craig nixon have used the term to
describe both alumni of the ranger
regiment
and graduates of the ranger school as
did the secretary of the army
as did most of my buddies in the army as
did most of the liberal media until a
conservative veteran was using the term
that way
but if some people disagree that's fine
i respect their views but what's most
important i respect the service of all
rangers
and indeed all soldiers who volunteered
to serve our country
well thank you for your service and i
want to give you a chance to clear that
up
senator thanks for the time thank you
brett